quantum computers
okay so the basic idea of quantum
computers that the promise of quantum
computers
is quantum mechanics does things in
parallel
and so you can sort of intrinsically do
computations in parallel
and somehow that can be much more
efficient than just doing them
uh one after another and you know i
actually
worked on quantum computing a bit with
dick feynman back in
1980 one two three um that kind of time
frame
and we have a fascinating image you you
and feinman work on quantum computers
well we tried to work the big thing we
tried to do was invent a randomness
chip that would generate randomness at a
high speed
using quantum mechanics and the
discovery that that wasn't really
possible
uh was part of the um the story of
we never really wrote anything about it
i think maybe he wrote some stuff but i
we didn't we didn't write
stuff about what we figured out about
sort of the fact
that it really seemed like the
measurement process in quantum mechanics
was a serious damper on what was
possible to do
in sort of uh you know the possible
advantages of quantum mechanics and
for computing but anyway so so the the
sort of the promise of quantum computing
is let's say you're trying to you know
factor an integer
well you can instead of you know when
you factor an integer you might say well
does this factor work does this factor
work does this factor work
um in ordinary computing it seems like
we pretty much just have to try all
these different factors
um you know kind of one after another
but in quantum mechanics you might have
the idea oh you can just
sort of have the physics try all of them
in parallel
okay and um the you know
there's this algorithm shaw's algorithm
which which
uh allows you according to the formalism
of quantum mechanics
to do everything in parallel and to do
it much faster than you can on classical
computer
okay the only little footnote is you
have to figure out what the answer is
you have to measure
the result so the quantum mechanics
internally has figured out all these
different branches
but then you have to pull all these
branches together to say and the
classical answer is this
okay the standard theory of quantum
mechanics does not tell you how to do
that
it tells you how the branching works but
doesn't tell you the process of
corralling all these things together
and that process which intuitively you
can see is going to be kind of tricky
but our model actually does tell you how
that process of pulling things together
works
and the answer seems to be we're not
absolutely sure we've only got to two
times three so far in
in uh you know which is kind of a in in
this um
in this factorization in quantum
computers but we can um
uh the you know what seems to be the
case is that the advantage you get from
the parallelization
from quantum mechanics is lost from the
amount that you have to spend pulling
together all those parallel threads to
get to a classical answer at the end
now that phenomenon is not unrelated to
various decoherence phenomena that are
seen in practical quantum computers and
so on
i mean i should say as a very practical
point i mean it's like
should people stop bothering to do
quantum computing research
no because what they're really doing is
they're trying to use
physics to get to a new level of what's
possible
in computing and that's a completely
valid activity
whether whether you can really put you
know whether you can say oh you can
solve an mp complete problem you can
reduce exponential time to polynomial
time
you know we're not sure and and i'm
suspecting the answer is no
but that's not relevant to the practical
speed ups you can get by using different
kinds of technologies different kinds of
physics
um to do basic computing but so you're
saying i mean
some of the models you're playing with
the indication is that
uh to uh get all the sheep back together
uh and you know
to corral everything together to get the
actual solution to the algorithm
is uh you lose all that you lose usually
by the way i mean so so again this
question do we actually
know what we're talking about about
quantum computing and so on so
again uh we're doing proof by
compilation
so we have a quantum computing framework
yeah in wolfram language
um which is you know a standard quantity
framework that represents things in
terms of the standard uh
you know formalism of quantum mechanics
and we have a compiler
that simply compiles the representation
of quantum gates
into multi-way systems so and in fact
the message that i got was from somebody
who's working on the project who
has managed to compile one of the sort
of
uh a core formalism based on category
theory um
and uh of core quantum formalism into
multi-wave systems
so this is a multiplayer system these
multi-way graphs yes
so you're you're compo yeah okay that's
awesome and then you can do
all kinds of experiments on that
multi-way graph right but the point is
that what we're saying is
the thing we've got this representation
of let's say shaw's algorithm
in terms of standard quantum gates and
it's just a pure matter
of sort of computation to just say that
is equivalent we will get the same
result
as running this multi-way system can you
do complexity analysis on that multi-way
system
well that's what we've been trying to do
yes we're getting there we haven't done
that yet i mean we
there's a pretty good indication of how
that's going to work out and we've done
as i say our computer experiments
we've unimpressively gotten to about two
times three
in terms of factorization which is kind
of about how far people have got with
physical
quantum computers as well but but that's
some but yes we will be able to we
definitely will be able to do complexity
analysis and we will be able to know
so the one remaining hope for quantum
computing really really working
at this formal level of you know quantum
brand exponential stuff being done in
polynomial time and so on
the one hope which is very bizarre is
that you can
uh kind of uh piggyback on the expansion
of branchial space
so here's here's how that might work so
you think you know energy conservation
standard thing in high school physics
energy is conserved right
but now you imagine you think about
energy in the context of cosmology and
the context of the whole universe
it's a much more complicated story the
expansion of the universe kind of
violates energy conservation
and so for example if you imagine you've
got two galaxies they're receding from
each other very quickly
they've got two big central black holes
you connect a spring
between these two central black holes
not easy to do in practice but let's
imagine you could do it
now that spring is being pulled apart
it's getting
getting more potential energy in the
spring as a result of the expansion of
the universe
so in a sense you are you are
piggybacking on the expansion that
exists in the universe
and the sort of violation of energy
conservation that's associated with that
cosmological expansion
to essentially get energy you're
essentially building a perpetual motion
machine
by using the expansion of the universe
and
that is a physical version of that it is
conceivable
that the same thing can be done in
branchial space to essentially
uh mine the expansion of the universe in
branchial space
as a way to get uh sort of uh
quantum computing for free so to speak
just from the expansion of the universe
in branchial space now the physical
space version is kind of absurd and
involves you know springs between
black holes and so on it's conceivable
that the braunshield space version is
not as absurd
and that it's actually something you can
reach with physical things you can build
in labs and so on we don't know yet
okay so yeah like you were saying the
branch of space might be
expanding and there might be some
something that could be exploited
right in the same kind of way that that
um that you can exploit
the um uh you know that expansion of the
universe in principle
in physical space you just have like a
glimmer of hope
right i think that the look i think the
real answer is going to be
that for practical purposes you know the
official brand that says you can
you can you know do exponential things
in polynomial time is probably not going
to work
you